hi Michael hi ELISA I absolutely loved
the film it was simply enough story and
a real weepy at times was it quite an
emotionally draining film to film uh it
made me sleep a lot it's quite tiring to
know when you're watching it alone no no
no and no no while we made the scenes
they're quite intense but it's more the
carry it was a lot of things where you
had to her dad to kind of uh you know go
straight in there and the hope that you
would find that the truth and a lot of
the kind of pain that these two
characters go through and that meant you
know it's at least I'm kind of like that
and real-life if I ever I'm very
emotional and whatever spectrum end of
the spectrum it is it's quite a physical
it's a physical thing being emotional so
it was it was some naps going on
blisters were you not absolutely
freezing like I did get think in all
those scenes that sighs did you see all
the role that they were I was really had
a great you know costume designer who
actually said I'm gonna come with you
yeah I'm not gonna let you freeze which
is needed at that scene in the rain
though going up the steps that's pretty
that was pretty yeah and one of the
scenes on the edge of the cliff words
not in the film like quite a lot of
scenes that we shot but yeah either the
wind there is pretty intense
and it was not summer in New Zealand
when we shot the film yeah what was it
it was actually also - going into winter
in yeah yeah
Florence Cleary and she was so adorable
like the whole room when I was there was
just in love with her at Oscar worthy in
my opinion and what she asked you as she
looked she she she was for when we shot
the film yeah very intelligent yeah yeah
she's you know it was pretty
extraordinary to sit her and just I mean
I did a few um improvisation that like
the first week like playing on the beach
and just to have a kid not look in the
lens of a camera because this is big
thing flying around everywhere that you
just want to kind of look yes I see
what's going on as you were just told if
she just didn't do that and she came up
with her own
stories about pirates and like I had to
fit I felt like I just had to step up
and like go with and not feel like I was
out of it and that I was in the game
with her which was pretty cool it's it's
often the case with kids I've won a few
times now yeah in terms of with scripted
dialogue they can tend to be quite sort
of restricted they've an almost sort of
like they're having to obey to certain
rules but when you allow them to
improvise there's just so much
imagination at play there and so much
freedom and like unless you said it's
kind of hard to keep up because it comes
out like a stream of consciousness but
with the script and when they're when
they're adhering to script that can be
where things get a little tricky
she was amazing that she's so good so if
you guys both lived in a remote
lighthouse on a tiny island nowadays
intint have Wi-Fi or TV what would you
take with you to keep you entertained
um boys food kind of somewhat music
musical instrument a surf portal good
one huh what no I picked an area
monopoly
oh darling sighs yeah
you